thank you for coming to see other people
please give it up for your host and
dating expert who has been on over 15
dates
hans kim
[Applause]
thank you guys hello hello
good to be here the mic is on
the music is also on
at the same time we're here we're dating
i'm single
the buckets full of names
someone's probably gonna get laid it
might happen
uh my name is hans kim and uh i'm
excited for this show
uh this is the first time we're doing it
so
i've never never done this before so
let's see how it goes you know uh
feelings might get hurt but
just remember it's all for the gram
this uh i got i have a guest on this
show so to kind of balance out the uh
autistic energy that i bring uh this is
this my guess is a very very funny
comedian she's been a huge part of the
austin comedy scene very funny please go
for bianca parado
[Applause]
thank you for being here bianca
hello everybody
this was not just a ruse to
try to date you yeah this is a
actually just a guest
on this very tiny table
[Music]
uh how's how's your dating life going
nowadays it's been better you know but
uh we're chugging along that's awesome
yeah this is uh my first date ever here
with yuan
yeah this is our first date uh but i'm
excited for the uh other people that are
gonna date because
i can live vicariously through them and
if they make a mistake that's not me so
that'll be fun yeah all right so how the
show works is i'll put i'll pull names
out of the bucket
and uh two names and then you guys will
come around this door and up the stairs
and have a date for three minutes and
after that we're going to interview you
and
at any point during the date uh you guys
can say
i need a lifeline and if you uh need a
lifeline we can give you a lifeline uh i
got some dating questions here
cast a google dating questions you know
cutest animal ugliest animal
so you guys could talk about that
what do you like to do on your free time
that's pretty standard
there's 160 of these
how many siblings do you have so these
are the kind of things that i'm willing
to provide for your day
uh
it's a it's gonna be a lifeline uh but
are you guys ready to get this show
started make some noise
[Applause]
[Music]
this bucket is just full of straight men
if there are not enough straight women
that signed up a few of you straight men
might have to go on dates with each
let's other prepared for that
but we're just out here making people
come off the closet
let's let's start with a straight couple
just to get the ball rolling okay so i'm
gonna pick two names a man and a woman
because gender norms this is texas no
just kidding
we love all people here we got
anal first date
and carl cochran
is anal first aid a real person
is that a question ain't no first date
maybe it's a knowledge
no no one by anal
no but you know chris cochran is coming
up
chris is coming up
and he's going to go on a date with
megan
[Music]
m-e-a-o g-e-n
so make your way to the stage
you can go up the steps he's athletic
ladies or you can go through the door
there's a little wooden door okay she's
also a parkour enthusiast give it up for
the two first dates pick up the mics and
let's go at it give it up for them
[Applause]
is this working
it is hello hey
it's nice to meet you
i will let you know that after three
minutes
you don't want to be like too hasty to
judge me
so i see you're a ginger
uh just here
oh i wasn't asking about the other parts
uh what brings you uh to this very
public date tonight
well i thought it would be cool for the
gram and actually i don't use instagram
i'm too [ __ ] old for that but
we have so much in common already
don't use instagram we both have barely
functional microphones
that's two things
so you're not here for the ground
oh um yeah uh facebook
okay cool is uh he filming on facebook
live right now oh uh that's for my uh
only fans continue okay cool
what's like can i ask like what your
only fan's handle is
it's uh
anal first date
[Laughter]
and here i was thinking i got curved
i don't get that reference but continue
um well uh anal first date um
it's this is a
it's great to uh it's great to be up
here with you
good to know
what else is
so from new
scale from one to ten how would you rate
all of this all of this
stuff here
you know i would say like an eight
i feel like this is going pretty well
um you asked me what's new lately what's
uh my brother is visiting me in town
that's my brother with the curly hair
why is your brother on our first date
well
[Laughter]
okay so you're from texas or alabama
making a lot of sense yeah yeah 30
seconds
so in 30 seconds tell me your life story
uh well i uh i promise not to fall
asleep i was uh conceived in connecticut
but i was born i
grew up in florida
uh he he spent some time there
um
i went to school
uh
i
i did i did some sports i went to
another school and then that's great so
let me tell you about me
time's up thank you guys so much for
going on a first date with just pick up
your microphones we're going to
interview you just sit right there we're
just going to figure out more about you
some some other things you could have
talked about uh so
how did you uh enjoy the date cochran
carl cochran and megan
what uh
what did you uh what is your overall
impressions and uh
what kind of vibes do you think would
would you guys go to like a buffalo wild
wings or olive garden
i take him to the [ __ ] circus
surfed us away that's kind of a bougie
day
i'm a new yorker so [ __ ] you man oh
you're from new york i i also lived in
new york for a while so that doesn't
make him a new yorker he's a he's a he's
a trainer i mean he was born in
connecticut he was born in connecticut
so what the [ __ ] is that that's um just
like the suburbs
okay so the the redhead cuts stepchild
you do have very unique
hair color your
brown hair and then your beard is ginger
i know that she referenced this but are
your pubes also ginger are they
burning
they are not do it for the only fans
i you know i mean i would be open
to dying if like that's what the only
fans needs dying in ginger
because he's asking for preference
so
you can see it later that's awesome i'm
sure that we'll see you on her only fan
soon you guys can make a
a duet together
fine find us on uh anal first date
only fans that's a good question would
you each
what are your opinions on anal on the
first day is that too fast
[Music]
who is receiving
that's a good question
or equal opportunity here
we've got an lgbtq bucket
i feel like he would like that
like the receiver i'm
oh here he goes
give it up for the sound guy yeah he's
actually going to join
you he's the cameraman
all watching their date you brought your
brother with you on your date is this
the first time you've seen your brother
dating
first dating
how are his other days what kind of
girls
he usually gets involved a little
further along are any of our are his
exes like good looking or
yeah if you guys saw each other on a
dating app would what would your
responses to each other be
us or me and my brother youtube
from florida
what is what is the first question that
you would ask knowing everything you
know now uh on on tinder what is the
first question that you'd ask
would you guys swipe on each other
i swear on
like less than one percent of people
so
is that a no i i don't know it's
personal it's not personal but you know
if you
are a chef do you where do you eat
fans if you're a chef what do you eat do
you eat at uh
john george's or mcdonald's
i think she just calls you mcdonald's
yeah
oh i see it
damn carl's down bad
we're planning a second date right now
um that was uh very interesting uh so
you do have an only fans and you also
signed up for the lgbtq bucket and i
don't have there's only fans sorry to
disappoint oh okay that was just a first
date lie
so handsome never showed up experience
[Music]
i mean first dates are a lot like improv
you got a yes
i can do them just because because
they're funny like they're you know
they're fun yeah don't match that often
so you know sometimes just like i'm
tired of swiping left let's just see
what happens
i have the opposite tinder approach i
just like set the phone on the table and
i don't even look at it and i just go
right
and then i just come through like
whatever
you know matriculated
if you have a hard time getting likes
it's easier to like everyone i get that
damn
[Music]
do you guys have any like um like
bugaboos any pet leaves no goes if
you're on the date and like
you know carl orders a steak well done
or you can't do this anymore like is
there any red immediate flags
i mean
like anybody who's rude to wait staff
for sure good one like if you're if like
if you know like even even if you're
just like a little snappy like with
waitstaff i'm just like get the [ __ ] out
of here be rude as you want with your
date but don't like disrespect the
people yeah
i mean that's what your date is fine you
can be rude to
so i agree
you can talk down to me you can
disrespect me but it's just not the
waiter
i think i would swipe right now
this data's improving as we speak
so uh what is some of the rudest things
you've seen dates do on first dates to
await staff
is there a particular example that comes
to mind
i don't know i remember once
when i was in high school me and my
my course my high school choir went to a
pizza restaurant and my friend's dad was
a chaperone and he was like
i ordered two pepperonis this one's just
got cheese
and i was like i would never date this
dude
that's good to know
that you wouldn't date your friend's dad
that's that's very rude
to waste that
um yeah i mean it's like that's someone
called for
i've had someone uh just walk out as i
was when i was doing this like in
college like
on you
i'm sorry yeah they walked at like this
old couple they walked out and didn't
pay the bill oh you were the waitress i
was yeah the whole [ __ ] bill like bro
uh you wanna pay so i will pay your bill
if you pay my [ __ ] student loans like
how about that so you don't like it when
people commit felonies yeah
that is like no
going dutch
um i had a date that paid for all my
food and then didn't give me a ride
to my home
you wanted both yeah
how did you get there
she i rode with my friends to her to
dallas and they were living in hers and
then
she was like come with me i was like
fine if you get me right back and then
she didn't give me a ride back did you
ever see her again no this happened like
two days ago
how did you get home yeah how did you
get back i took a 50 lift
they're so expensive now i know you
could have like started a relationship
with the driver that sounded like 150
bucks yeah i mean
the funniest thing is it's han
was also a car too so it's like if you
just want to drove you would have
already i would have been home already
[Music]
i live in a van so
now
let's move this over here so everyone
can see my face
uh but
yeah i mean uh so
what did you guys uh think about this
show is this like a good way to meet
people you think
would you guys talk
yeah i i would i would chat with you
afterward you want to grab a drink after
this oh i don't drink
do you want to
have
anal i don't i don't i don't
right to the animal who is receiving
you know you're
you're choice
dealer's choice
you guys are getting rochambeau for it
what are your guests
is that like sign language for fisting
no it was just rock paper scissors
so bianca what do you think about these
two beautiful this beautiful couple
megan and carl cochran
[Music]
i uh i would like to see this work out
i'm not gonna lie
but if i'm also not gonna lie i don't i
don't know
you know you're pretty nice too hans
thanks man
i feel like we're honestly you want to
sit over here
i can't expect him that's gonna happen
next it's gonna happen between us too
hey i'll be right there
with his brother
and pov like carl's giving some kind of
sexy eye contact
i think he's serious
he looks like a
look like a pirate he's got pirate
facial hair
carl put his name in all three buckets
all right give it up for
megan and carl cochran thank you guys so
much for being the first ever date on
other people a live dating show
and there's the handshake of love
the sign of a successful date
um
so that was the first one uh any
thoughts should we debrief that was that
was fun
yeah that was um that that was
interesting to walk that was like
it was like love on the spectrum you
know
just put it all out there
there's like two cats going at it it's
beautiful to see
uh let's do another because we only have
one name in here now
wait is there only one thing oh this is
a straight woman bucket there's only one
more name in the straight women bucket
good thing there's a lot more women in
here so we can just point
and follow are we demonstrating women's
treatment no let's say let's say it's a
straight woman for last first we're
saving her up
the last one
uh well
where there's only two names in here so
we're gonna see megan again with
threesome with lady oh this is another
question threesome with [ __ ] that's
that's not okay well wait do we have an
actual any actual couples in here yeah
at one point we should make i think we
should make a couple come up here at
some point and do what to eat we should
have two couples talk to each other oh
we should have them swap
life squad
so if you guys are you guys down for a
wife swap who's here or a husband swap
you guys are down for that
and any any other couple down for a
couple swap not this guy you guys now
have a couple swaps
no why don't we just have the couple
come up here and go on a date before
uh let's ask us let's see what they know
about each other yes you guys want to
come up here and go on a date for us
all right give it up for this couple
we're gonna go on a date with each other
[Applause]
bianca said let's ruin their marriage
let's try to
find out things that they don't want us
to know
letting the woman on the center stage
okay and here they go three minutes of
couples talking to each other wait
what's your guys's name first and how
long have you been dating
my name is holly holland and we've been
together for
a little over a year now wow yeah 15
months i'm brian
a little over a year 15 months okay
all right here you guys go and do what
you do normally
hey so uh what's your name
we are not doing that
you mean you don't want to start all the
way over with no
i mean that wasn't like 15 months of
hard work that we put in
uh yeah no we can skip all that
where are we at where are we dating it
uh we can go to that uh that comedy club
oh right the creek
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna go check that
out i heard i don't know we almost got
lost on the way to the creek and cave
because i was looking for either a creek
or a cave
and
the only cave that i could see was like
the
drainage ditch which is also a creek in
the cave it's it's all in one yeah i
don't know there was something very very
like
charming about it something was drawing
me in
yeah so we almost took the right turn
yeah exactly
we did
so how do you like our new apartment
i love our new apartment
yeah so we moved out of an apartment
that uh was infested with wasps
and uh i was feeling how many a day like
like six a day like six walls a day yeah
one of them almost murdered our cat and
that's the that's the story about wasps
fun fact uh wasps they don't like cold
environments they slow down just like
flies do so if you ever see a fly like
land on something cold they get still
whilst kind of do the same thing
yeah i have a similar reaction to cold
in certain areas of my body
i don't know if y'all can guess which
so i'm meeting your grandparents soon
yeah
you are
it's gonna be interesting yeah this is
uh the point before they get senile so
uh
yeah although i think it might be more
entertaining to meet them once they are
yeah that's true stories will get pretty
odd and it's weird it's like equal parts
sad and entertaining yeah you know
sendility senility
well i won't bail on you if you become
senile
can we do cute stuff here
that'll be great i can trick you easier
oh yeah
because right now she's smarter than me
so i need i need to be the smarter one
in the relationship
tell me about your life in 30 seconds
something i don't know
i'm a chef and i love my life and i'm a
proud woman
what are you proud of
i'm proud of my power you're not proud
of your man
jesus
time's up give it up for this couple
brian and his lovely girlfriend
what holly holland holly holland your
full name
you're full that's that's the
obliteration yeah
it's easier to
remember the second person to say that
i usually get weather reporter superhero
but porn star was one you sound like
captain america for holland
you're a
wonder woman for holland
uh you guys said
he said tell me something i don't know
about you in 30 seconds and you said
that you're a chef you're happy and
you're a proud woman
are these things like he doesn't know
about you
it doesn't know
um so you're a chef do we know the
restaurant you chef at i uh i'm a pastry
chef at la bache it's out here uh
dripping springs
so we can all go there for a discount
do you cook a lot of room at home i do
yeah a lot of like like mainly bakery
items no i
so i eat a lot of sweets at work so
whenever i come home it's all savory
okay i want all the salt do you like her
cooking
i love it oh yeah this guy's living
well not only is she a chef but she
likes all the same like flavor profiles
that i do is there anything that she's
made that you don't like
i feel like there is but i can't
remember there was one good answer
yeah and it's overshadowed by all the
numerous good
you know times thanks man
i feel like we're helping the
relationship and it's not funny
it's very therapeutic you guys have a
similar flavor profiles you also have
similar glasses profiles you guys are
very scary glasses
do you guys have similar prescriptions
her eyes are worse
yeah i'm legally blind
i can't leave the house without
corrective lenses
also only for pupils i mean blind people
can leave their house
i just need to get me a cane and work on
that
you can get a dog you can run around oh
my god life would be so scary if i
walked out in the world without my
glasses guys
just bring your seeing eye cat that
almost got
killed by a wasp
that wouldn't be very helpful where was
this wasp was it in your like patio dude
i don't know how they were getting in
but they were they would just be in and
they'd be like on the sliding glass door
on the fan like all over
that's terrible that's terrifying
cockroaches are bad but they're not
gonna they don't sing you yeah exactly
that's deadly too your cat got stung
yeah on the mouth oh yeah it's probably
swatting at it trying to protect your
hand yeah you got it slain did you take
it to the vet no no he's fine
you guys said that you met in high
school
yeah
how old are you guys
30 and 31 and you've only been dating so
you guys knew each other and then you
didn't yeah so if you want to know the
full story
we
we dated for a couple of months uh we
went to prom together
i dumped him on prom day for another
person for another person we didn't
speak for about 13 years
oh
until last year in august i hid him up
on instagram during the pandemic oh it
was weird dude it was weird too because
yeah well there's that but um
but yeah i was just talking to a friend
about like some music that she had
showed me like not with this
conversation didn't start with her on my
mind but like it brought me there
because we were talking about like the
shins and like animal collective and
stuff and she introduced me to all those
so
um i was like oh i wonder what holly's
doing i look on instagram and she's
followed me like that same day
oh wow
yeah a huge coincidence yeah that's very
coincidental you guys are meant to be
how did you feel how did you feel about
hallie before she dm'd you like were you
still mad about prom oh no no it was
high school
yeah
so actually guys what we didn't tell you
is we have the guy from prom here
tonight
you want to come on now
she's gonna dump you again oh my god
this is all very alive you know in the
name of comedy that would be i it would
be worth it
on his knees with his little electric
bike and helmet on at a gas station and
begged me to stay in the relationship
and i was like nobody that old prom guy
or this guy the little guy
the prom date guy
oh that's this guy that's the prom date
oh the other dude
the other guy you're like i'm a texan i
want an oil guzzling
vehicle
how long did it last after you dumped
this guy with the other guy
you just keep going over this guy
brian
brian and holly
so
i dated that guy for about five years
and
it was another
seven years
we were just waiting for another prom to
break up with him
but um coincidentally turned right
around their high school reunion
oh he didn't show up to the high school
reunion i was really bummed
i was hoping yeah
he was in maui
where did you guys go to high school mr
ridge
cedar park cedar park oh okay around
here
so you guys are austin natives yeah
that's awesome do you know them were
they cute in high school
hopefully you don't think so because
that would be illegal so
that's awesome so you work in tech now
and
you work in downtown as a chef
you guys are where'd you guys go for the
first date
um actually she i was living in san
antonio and she came down and we cooked
together
and just kind of hung out like caught up
anal first date
actually
[Laughter]
nice catholic couple
do you guys have any pet peeves against
each other
like what if okay what's your one for oh
do you have a list we can go there
i want to hear each um
she she has this thing where she clears
her throat a lot while we're watching
movies
and like and i feel bad because she
can't help it but i can't help but
want to hear the movie
so this guy
is always listening to the movies so i
have to just shove it down and not
mention it i know it bothers me thank
you for giving me the opportunity to to
cathart on stage well uh you're gonna
have some cough drops
i feel like that's i don't know if that
would make it worse or better okay
is it like an allergy
that's fine
it's just at the top always sparkles
[Music]
just totally damaged
honey yeah we're about to watch a movie
you want to start gargling
i like that movie
i i hope gargling happens at some point
i think that'd be worse
or whatever
i feel like it would you know benefit
you in other ways yeah yeah that's my
thought too i i had never really stopped
yeah natural lube
there you go
i'm gonna try that tonight
yeah so you guys
so you guys been dating for a year you
guys live around downtown austin we just
moved off of slaughter in 35
okay so
not too far we have to hear holly's pet
peeve yeah oh what's your pet peeve
about brian um
brian whenever i turn on my music
he'll
get
an urge to
make up his own version of the song
it's a regular weird al yankovic yeah
but not as good it's a it's a lot of
noises and humming and
and it's very loud at times too he's got
it he's got a lot of volume on him
he's got some pipes on him oh man what
what song has he done that that really
annoys you
oh god
some ed sheeran or i can't even say
honestly
it's just that
just happens hey but when you think
about it though his love for music is
what brought him back to your profile
music you know
he is a big lover of music yeah well i
wonder if the sound guy could help us
with some shins and brian could show us
some of his comedic talents
who wants to hear brian make a song
funny
[Applause]
can we get australia by the shins and
the it's literally just me singing like
gibberish lyrics that make no sense
yeah yeah let's hear it
let's uh see your creative mind at work
oh god
[Music]
ryan pretend you're alone in a car with
your
beautiful girlfriend
you're just feeling good about yourself
you're loving life this is a serenade
trying to make her laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah brian ladies and gentlemen
give it up for his
musical talent he's doing an hour after
the show
he's our opener now uh you can catch him
at the next one but thank you guys so
much for coming up here and
showing us your conversation and
we love you
we love you thank you holly holly and
brian one more time
[Applause]
oh
what number is this
too many to count oh we should bring
them up
you guys want to go after this next
couple
you guys yes that's a yes we're coercing
so uncomfortable which makes me just
want to do this more so
she's going yeah i am
well you guys have time to prepare
because right now we got salmon swift
and kristi vera
we got chrissy vera in the house here
she is give it up for this lovely couple
a handshake of love
and here we go
yeah she's ready
uh three minutes of hot dating action
and here we go
put some good words in uh
hi guys um
i love your hair and your eyes are so
beautiful wow you look lovely as well
are you single
no
where's your girlfriend
she's in new york so we have nothing to
worry about
tough guy from new york
yeah you can say that do you guys live
in your own apartment we do not
what does that mean
um so she lives in an apartment and i
live in a different one but um but we
live close by each other so
that's nice yeah that is cute sometimes
we run into each other on the street oh
yeah
dude i get caught at the grocery store a
lot really makeup on yeah oh my god that
sounds just like the scenario i just
talked about are you are you sure
you know when sugar like like messes
with your brain yeah yeah
yeah i i ate like a little bit of
mushrooms earlier so it sounds very
similar no it's like the opposite i
think oh really yeah you're just kind of
like a pillowy
rainbow right right and mine is more of
like a cocaine yeah
like a bad thing yeah right right right
yeah
okay gotcha so where are you from oh
yeah
new york oh really
yeah
perfect
okay
wait are you from new york too
which part
wait you're on a date with me i'm from
new york
i'm also from new york
do you guys when people say
what where they're from in new york do
you guys care
i do okay what neighborhood are you from
fort greene well i live in fort worth
[Music]
that's where people make babies yeah
that's the plan that's where all the
rich babies are in like strollers yeah
like that yeah yeah so something to
aspire to i mean maybe if this works out
you know we could make a little four
greenhouse oh yeah
so is that where you're from lower east
uh lower east side oh that's unfortunate
yeah i mean it's fun yeah no it's
definitely fun but where people like
parties right right yeah but you can't
party with a baby that's what fort
greene's for
yeah what do you do to like
move around do you go around by a train
um train bicycle walk you know all sorts
of stuff
how do you how do you travel people just
order ubers for me but um
oh yeah
let's figure out how
i really like you oh my god i'm so glad
you said it i was too nervous dude
i like your outfit
how long are you gonna be here
um two weeks
yeah i got here today
what are you here for uh thanksgiving
and um i appreciate your family my
brother lives here yeah yeah
you guys have a nice house uh
yeah it's pretty nice i mean it's his
house but you look like you guys have
like a fence and stuff oh there's a
fence yeah yeah yeah
time's up for this beautiful couple good
enough for the new york couple chrissy
barra and salmon swift
your real name is sam
no what's your real name
miles cochran
miles jennings miles jennings oh he had
a fake name too yeah
that's awesome so
you guys are a new york couple that's
wonderful
yeah what's the symbol of a new york
couple uh a young guy
started swearing at each other
yeah i'm walking here
in a yankees hat yeah we are what yeah
why are you asking forget about it
why are you asking what do you want to
know
sam and swift uh
went on a date tonight with a girlfriend
and mentioned her right away that's a
bold move man hey you know gotta gotta
gotta keep the values strong you know
as long as you make it known it's not
wrong they said she's far away yeah
exactly yeah yeah kirsty how did you
feel about him having a girlfriend are
you faced by it unfair literally
i think it's cute that they walk around
over there you know but
we have
we have thanksgiving to think about yeah
we do so i'll bring the turkey
i'll bring the condoms
wow christy making a lot of promises
are you on the first date
first date
you guys don't do things on your first
date
well i try very hard
apparently they host a stand-up uh
routine or at first dating routine on
their first date yeah yeah we're
interviewing you now
how's it going i mean like are you
feeling a love connection yeah i mean i
haven't really been making eye contact
yeah honestly i must say you're doing
quite poorly
you made more eye contact with carl you
know
hands-on
um
you said that uh
you know you like you did mushrooms
today just a little bit just a micro
dose yeah yeah yeah and do you think
that helps on dates of course it makes
you more in the moment yeah you should
give it a shot what's something that you
would say on a date on mushrooms that
you wouldn't literally everything i've
said so far
so you take mushrooms and you tell dates
that you have a girlfriend yeah that's
usually how it goes have you ever tried
you know not not too bad
yes the answer is yes i yeah i i um just
anal i slipped up you know i i kissed
somebody one time just kiss yeah yeah
yeah i could do more if if i had any say
in it yeah
wait till turkey day
oh i feel like we're initiating an
affair
that's the thing with guys is like
all of the loyalty that they have is
just under the control of any girl that
they run into yeah especially that makes
sense yeah yeah except for like all that
majority of the guys that don't cheat
i mean it's not like every guy cheats
right some of them don't it's all it's
only the select few
salmon does them
i mean this is being streamed live on
youtube so yeah
hopefully she doesn't watch youtube yeah
it's a pretty big website she's never
heard of it
uh new york right now how is it is uh is
there a lot of love in the air a lot of
dates happening or what do you do for a
living it's too cold i wouldn't know i'm
i'm taken
um
no it's it's pretty good you know
there's a lot of love in here it's fall
the leaves are changing isn't it hard to
have love at first sight with all the
masks
we don't really wear masks that much
anymore yeah everybody in texas thinks
it's so bad no it's not it's just just
like here well you know we have freedoms
here so yeah
that's true
freedom is the best aphrodisiac that's
true yeah i'm feeling aroused already
where where would you go with christie
on your first date if it weren't on
stage
be nice yeah
um it seems like thanksgiving dinner is
a really strong bet like i would go
check out the animals behind the fence
yeah house yeah there are plenty
yeah it's his house yeah yeah yeah you
live on a farm
why do you have animals behind the fence
so you're just lying the names are a lie
what what
what is real do you have a fence
what animals are at uh your brother's
house
does he have any pets um
apparently there are lizards i just got
here you know i haven't really i haven't
really scoped out the whole house so
christy if he uh would you leave him
salmon for his brother carl you said
salmon that's right
okay okay would i leave him some salmon
no would you leave him for his brother
carl because carl are you single
no
megan's heartbroken right now
uh
look
[Music]
i would go check out the lizards um
what
what is there a lot of commitment in
this
sorry why do you love animals so much me
are you hungry because you because
no i just ate a doughnut it's all a
lizard like oh what are you
hungry it is that's what we do in asia
it establishes touching
yeah you can start touching it you talk
you talk like sexually and autistically
and then something comes along and you
go
you're both trying to talk to them
let me rub your belly and then uh
and then he's like i want my belly
rubbed
who are you dating
they're like oh i like how you're
rubbing the pet can you start rubbing
meanness
is this getting you a hot and bothered
i'll tell her all about the rabbits
he's gonna start rolling over and
playing fetch just to get a little
action exactly
so is there a lot of similarities you
think between
touching pets and touching
men on dates i think there are too many
to count really
i mean
what
you know i often like to treat my pets
like my women you know
should we
she is a woman how do you how do you
treat your pets
oh i was i was
being you oh
how long have you been dating your
girlfriend uh two years event yeah
are we is it time to let her go
i don't think so
okay yeah what do you guys do in new
york together you go
to the world trade center
yeah pay your respects
we we truly never forget we go every day
it's a great day yeah
you uh fort green is like mid brooklyn
right like near dumbo
near green yeah it's like between dumbo
and williamsburg so you could uh
go to the park watch a movie at the park
yeah what do you do for a living
um i go to the world trade center
uh what's your job oh no i i i work in
sales for a tech company you would think
i would live in austin right right yeah
because they don't have tech in new york
no that doesn't make sense yeah i know
yeah
no that's awesome you uh sell things
yeah
what uh what tech are you selling
uh insurance technology nice for uh yeah
jesus christ
how thrilling
your date's as dry as a bone right now
exactly dry as ground zero yeah
nice
you're head of
chris you're talking about it to a guy
with a promotion yeah wow
wow promote yeah promote these nuts
promote your nuts to christy i ate
donuts yeah they're i actually have tons
of donuts in my car really outside yeah
if you want something okay
there are these like they're these
crusty dry
donuts that they're actually kind of
good yeah very old they're doing a great
job selling them yeah
it's this place called ken's donuts on
guadalupe they're like very old donuts
we got paints in there when i think of
godot yeah but they're kind of good
though even though they're old and
crusty
yes yes we actually have a pastry chef
here who can
judge the quality of your donuts yeah
yeah i'll bring them in after the i
don't know yeah let's bring it in three
donuts for everyone yeah i'll leave them
at the bar
yeah
how old
i don't know but you guys agree right
okay yeah this is the thing you did
during the day
sorry sorry yeah i should be more
supportive they're really old
your brother your brother right you've
been there yeah
ken's donuts it's good
but uh you know that they're old
okay
christy likes to talk to everyone on
in in the
restaurant on a date
oh yeah they're just on a date like you
guys agree right
he's hot right hey
look at this guy uh thank you guys so
much for coming out and dating and uh
you know don't tell your girlfriend that
you did this absolutely not or do she
might be into it give it up for sam and
swift and christy vera thank you guys so
much for coming out
uh so
we got one name in the lgbtq bucket
she can go on a date with herself and we
got one more name here oh we were gonna
do you guys right you guys want to come
up here
give it up for this couple they're going
to go on a date
in front of us
what are your names
zach and olia
sounds good together there's a lot of
interracial dating on this show i think
we're bringing together
diverse groups it starts with the panel
yeah
give it up for aaliyah and zack
is it jess yeah it just makes your voice
loud yep
thanks for complaining to me
oh god it's already bad
so what's going on well i think it's
kind of funny because i totally knew
this was gonna happen well no no no on
the way over i was thinking about like i
need to tell zach that i'm gonna stop
drinking and then we sat down and i was
like i'm not gonna drink anymore and
then i immediately ordered a drink and
i've just been thinking about that so
good
so i need to tell you
thanks i mean it's okay because i yeah
like i said i don't think you best for
me drinking is like more of a lifestyle
than like just something you do
so like when you said i'm gonna stop
drinking it didn't make a lot of sense
because i never really took you as
someone who drank a lot but like i
dreamed yeah you you partake okay
so it wasn't like anything like it was a
moment for me
yeah all right
so
only the most upsetting thoughts that
are gonna make us fight are popping into
my head
[Music]
i think we
remember when you uh asked me to move in
together
[Music]
we came to a good agreement what was the
agreement well we have two sets we have
two separate houses oh yeah like free to
call them yeah yeah yeah but there's a
bridge and we meet in the middle well
that's like important because i like my
space and i like myself and you like
your space
so
yeah yeah
um
what what'd you think of the play we saw
earlier i thought i mean i thought it
was like
good for
like
a college play
i think so too
yeah
i don't know if i'm i don't know if
yeah
what did you think it looked like
i think it was good i think you you
don't like when i have a lot of strong
opinions no i don't like when you say
your opinions in like
factual ways
30 seconds
it doesn't really sound like an opinion
we're like no this is true
yeah it's my opinion that is true it's
true that it's my opinion okay but
that's a different conversation
yeah
well my opinions about the play were
that i thought it was yeah i told you i
agree
and that's time
there we go with the opinions of
[Applause]
aaliyah and zach
they say it's been five weeks but they
sound like they've been married for
years
i love i don't like that you state your
opinions in factual ways
she was holding that for a while
i've heard that one before
so what are some of your most factual
opinions that you've you've stated
which one's really important to you too
i'm sure ali would remember more than me
uh
i mean i just
i come from a family that likes to argue
for fun you know and so a white family
yeah
so when you're trying to be heard
growing up you learn to speak things
like you really know them for fact are
you irish
no not all red heads are irish hots that
is pretty racist
sure also i didn't like all the the
ginger appropriation earlier that was
kind of messed up it's kind of bottom
ginger
yeah
situation because i got the red hair but
like the blonde facial hair
blonde
so aaliyah do you have an opinion of his
that sticks out when you think of what
he does as factual
or whatever you know what i'm saying
meanings of words we'll just talk about
like like this word means this and like
actually i think it means this and i'm
like actually i think words mean like
specific things
like there's a dictionary yeah they have
but they have multiple entries in the
dictionary they got the number one two
three so there are multiple meanings
well there are multiple meanings but
they're not like
what you think like they're not just
like i've decided this is what this
means what's the word that uh
zach
you think it means one thing and then
liam thinks it means another i think
opinion no
opinion and fact the idea of opinions
and facts are like very
oh this is getting very vague and
abstract
most of our conversations what plane did
you guys see uh the arsonist who wanted
to go
to the play i wanted to go oh he took
you to a play yeah yeah he's a theater
person yeah we it was it's the theater
group from college where we met
okay were you guys both in theater yes
ah so where did you guys go on your
first date and how did you guys re-link
from when did you decide to make that
five-year friendship into
a potential dating scenario
and living scenario i guess
and did you guys say break a leg when
you started
yeah
i think that was the problem because we
dated once and broke up and then now we
got back together but the first time we
dated i was in australia for like
four of the six months that we were
dating is that why you broke up just
because it was long distance no
surprisingly enough that was the easiest
part
oh
let's dig deeper okay
why did you guys break up then i only
hear one from i want to hear your each
person's
version she goes
oh
no
oh this is how we start fights this is
this is where opinion in fact
me um
wait where why we broke up the first
time yeah okay uh
we're gonna make them break up again
live on stage i'm so scared
no you guys are
good oh is that the first time she said
i love you
no
but we can pretend it is okay
i give it up for that
professional actors
pretending to love each other on stage
yeah okay so why did you guys break up
the first time
the easiest part was the distance
uh
i
so i remember breaking up okay so
i was directing the play at the time
and
she was my stage manager
and we were
doing auditions and
i think we were fighting i don't even
remember what the fights were about but
i remember breaking up and you calling
me
and you were like i don't know if this
is gonna work and then i was like
well if you don't know then i guess
that's like the right answer or
something like that and then
and then i hung up and we were broken up
and then i was like wait a second i
should have like said something else and
then i was like oh i'm sad i punched the
roof of my car and drove home crying
and then we did you didn't know that did
you know he punched
the punch
why do you think the hole was there
he's incredibly strong like it always
i always get wet when it rains in your
car
[Music]
so it was probably like an argument
about like stage lighting or set
decoration
no that but i would not recommend
directing a show with your ex-girlfriend
not a
not like an emotionally
healthy thing creative endeavor no yeah
it doesn't really foster a really
creative environment because you have to
sort of be a dictator if you're a stage
director
you shouldn't but
it is yeah i'm sure i pissed her off a
lot
did his version line up to what you
think happened
um i mean yeah i think that sounds about
right the reason for me was just like i
felt like i wasn't getting enough
potential and so that was like yeah he
was in australia
and like it was looking at kangaroos
and like i was like well i'm cuter than
them so and that was the whole thing you
know yeah
who made the move to get back to restart
it up again
well
she reached out to me first but then i
think i kind of tricked her into staying
yeah why because she
because we didn't talk for like a year
and a half two years and then it was
like in march yeah you hit me up and
well because okay because i had sub
tweeted you yes and then you sent me
this long message and then you put her
on a story and then well you guys got
back together through twitter
actually i would say yes because
because you sent me this long message
and i was like this is [ __ ] and then
like several months have passed after
like the postmortem of that and i was
like oh what if i was friends with zak
again and so then i texted you to be
friends and then
now we're here
i was like
i know you thought
that's beautiful
um
so you guys say you have two houses and
then there's a bridge in between so does
that mean you guys have three houses
three houses holy crap how do you guys
manage that in this
in this economy i think we're also like
frida kahlo
so we're like independently wealthy it's
a hypothetical
he won't move in with her
oh yeah
what was the twitter beef
i wrote a about
and
you beeped your play
well
i i he didn't watch it so i was like
upset about that but he's since watched
it so it's fine
oh you wrote a play and he didn't watch
it yeah
[ __ ]
yeah there was a little bit of
misunderstanding because there was
one character in the play that i thought
was like based on me who was also like
the villain kind of not really and we've
since like come around on that
discussion
the character was in australia yeah so
like i was like i don't want to like
show up to my ex's
opening weekend of her play where i'm
like a bad guy in the play and then like
be there
was the character based on him no
she would like to say yeah she just put
like my habits on this character
or maybe you're just like a person with
normal people
a villain
you have villainy type half it's one of
the habits that you saw the villain that
you thought were yours well it's because
i was uh a relationship therapist
basically what could you identify in the
character that you saw in yourself it
was because uh
i was a business major so i thought i
was going to go and like do all sorts of
like i don't know random consulting or
just business so this character was like
obsessed with business and then
like
she hates when i crack my knuckles or
pop my joints
that's what every i hate whenever
yeah so this character also did that a
lot
those are the two
those are all this guy this character
had a job and popped his
i might be the bad guy
that's sweet you didn't want to be a bad
guy in her life and uh you took it
personally because you're very sensitive
you're an artist you do plays and
uh now you guys are together and now
it's uh beautiful and you guys are
working it out and
you know towards those three houses yeah
are you guys official like are you
boyfriend girlfriend or you just stay
would you guys say you're exclusive
yes
we say that because normally
i'm
she's the one that would be less
wanting to get committed so
is that true
are you guys going to write a play
together
no
different writing maybe a podcast but
you know not a play
he goes
that's cool
uh
uh you know moving in together frida
kahlo what does that mean frida kahlo
she's a person
hopefully things go well married one day
i'm like i want to have our own bedrooms
and maybe like a family room connect in
the middle and then you don't have to
like
you know i think that makes sense it's
just a two-bedroom house
well i don't like that
see we're looking for like two one bets
all right give it up for this couple
zach and aaliyah thank you guys so much
for coming
that was amazing
we're getting to know so many people on
this show it's great
uh we got our last couple coming up
right now
uh it's gonna be a straight couple
because that's the only couple's left we
got cara the queen kara the queen
with cody
give it up for cody and kara the queen
the last couple i really hope that
somebody one of these stranger couples
works out and i don't think that it's
going to be megan and carl so that's
really hope
this is our last hope for a successful
other people relationship get up for a
cara the queen and cody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
how's your day going it's been all right
okay so it's been busy uh it's the one
week from here that i really have over
time and
it's really up until thanksgiving and
then i'm off until next year really oh
nice what do you do
i work uh
internet sales is really the easiest way
to explain it a lot of sales a lot of
sales tonight
okay interesting i i don't enjoy it but
i enjoy the money it makes me okay
that's fair
uh what about you what do you do for a
thing uh
ethics and compliance which is boring
but
um
okay
lifeline thank you for using the
lifeline for the first time
uh
i lost the thing
what's your social security number
what country do you never want to visit
another lifeline when was the last time
you walked for more than an hour
yesterday
and why
i used to be a boy scout i like to hike
my friends and i went i think yesterday
where did y'all go hiking slaughter
creek okay that's the opposite direction
i went towards georgetown oh yeah no
we're
south southern
do you guys go hiking together
uh yeah
i like to go hiking
30 seconds
how many lifeline questions
this
is your second date today
what is the most ridiculous thing you've
done because you were bored
i started making a kilt recently okay
like weaving it
and time
keep it going for a care of the queen
and cody
cody the kilt maker
are you uh do you have scandinavian
roots or swedish roots
mostly all right that's irish
is the other half
okay
it's funny because uh you cara looks
very responsible and like she has a job
and uh cody
i mean jeez it looks
looks like you need a job
could you hire cody at your job do you
think you have an opening
luckily i don't have to manage people
anymore so it's just me it wasn't
they're going to be going on a hike soon
so that might be an hr problem for them
to work together and again i'm in
compliance ethics and compliance
but see kara's a dog though this is her
second date of the night
cody you're just another piece of meat
you know what is this go go to ciao
she's like just keep them out you know
how do you feel about that cody
this is my first date in
months so i'm content give it up for
cody he's putting himself out there
[Applause]
so a month ago you went on a date or two
several months ago
how'd that date go
i threw up
from nervousness or dislike i had a
mid-sex panic
attack called that
you threw up during sex did you make it
to the bathroom yes
i didn't need to stop good sex could you
imagine you're hooking up with a guy and
he's like i'm gonna throw up i'd be like
this is
is that just what you call ejaculation
throwing up
i threw up all over your chest
i wish that would have been so much
easier because i had to drive her home
afterwards
what made you throw up did you have like
a stomach flu
uh had previous very bad relationships
so just
yeah so you were like traumatized and
that's yeah
[Music]
is now you know if it ever happens again
you were like pre-warmed you know
just bring one of those bags in
nice long airplanes and rub his back
make him eat saltine crackers you know
the usual fun sex stuff that
we all do
so cara you went on a date today
and where did you guys go stubs
no sushi
ooh sushi my people's cuisine
how was how was the day what happened
not anything memorable why didn't you
like it
should we call him
he's also here right now
look he's got a line of former lovers
i want to do that with kids
you do not support sleeping with kids on
other people
here's the beauty of this concept
that is a question that you can't ask
for like you know three or four dates in
maybe who knows i don't know but we're
just getting it out on the table right
now you know
we saved you some some fine fine dollar
bills that you would have spent on
dinner
so you want lots of kids i i do i've
always wanted a very large family you
guys yeah you dress like that
well i want lots of funny pictures for
the kids to look at and say look how
weird dad used to dress dress you look
like a free spirit like you like to have
fun and
uh so you you do sales on the internet i
think megan suggested that you're a drug
dealer
uh blink once if it's true
[Music]
okay he uh
neither confirmed or denied it
but uh this guy doesn't smoke weed at
all you know
completely sober
that was just a
dramatic kara do you are you a 420
friendly uh
sure
do you blaze kara
no but would you with cody i mean
see
i think that you guys can maybe come to
a middle because i feel like even if you
don't want kids if you guys date it'd be
kind of like you had them anyway you
know just
yeah
are you implying that she should just
get stoned i just need a house
yeah yes
you're just a big
child
don't have children just marry a child
yeah that's yeah that's a good enough
thank you you've
put the right words in my mouth
i don't like that you stated your
opinion like it was a fact
[Music]
so uh would you guys ever get a house
with a bridge in between it
i like i like my own state so i can do
that i like my own space but that just
sounds like too much house
i'd be happy with my own bedroom
maybe you could have a shared living
space like a kitchen yeah yeah
a family room yeah for the family maybe
uh maybe a second bedroom or two yeah
but a separate bathroom would help
oh yeah there'd be probably at least
three bathrooms there'd be one
cody where would you take cara on the
first date
uh
do you like italian sure i have a coupon
for mandolas
he's a thrifty dater how do you feel
about it
i am using a coupon on the first day
yeah okay that's good she accepts you
for who you are cody
this is a beautiful couple you guys
could each braid each other's hair
you guys are both in skirts
what made you knit a kilt like are you
guys are you going to go to renaissance
fair or you're going to wear it on 6th
street
yes to all at the above i've already
been to the renaissance festival a
couple of times i'm going again
this coming weekend with my family i
won't get killed unfortunately it's
going to take probably at least this
next year to make it because
and i don't have an actual loom i'm just
doing it really you're free freehand you
don't have your own loom bro i don't
have a i don't have an actual loom i'm
using it's mostly cardboard and two
[Music]
[Applause]
i like how you're freehanding your way
into freeballing
cara would you go to a
renaissance festival do you does that
line up with any of your interests not
really but
you guys are [ __ ]
i don't know no kids you got you got the
hype thing going for you you guys are
gonna go on a hike but then he's gonna
go smoke weed and go to a renaissance
fair
while you make six figures
[Laughter]
how old are you guys
i asked cody
are you guys kind of into
that what about you cody you want to do
children one i i have no problem with
older women i think my my upper age max
would probably be about 38
to 10 years above me because i'm almost
28. let me introduce you to helen mirren
she would love to go on a date with you
she would like to go hiking and
she's actually got a loom she's british
sounds exciting
so you say you wouldn't want to go to
north korea would you go to south korea
oh yeah probably okay good answer i'm
south korea
god is just fact-checking people on
stage yeah you'd still go to the place
with my people right
yes i had a very bad experience with
sushi my first time so i i steer your
made your vomit yeah that way you know
where you went on the last day
we're talking dnd stats with a very low
constitution score
what
this is some renaissance fair share are
you just making what's a constitution
score
where were you on january 6th yeah
where were you on 9 11 cody
[Music]
miss copeland's class
so carol where were you on 9 11
in high school
she was making money in the world trade
center
[Laughter]
would you guys vacation with each other
where would you go
i want to go back to cozumel because
it's been a while since i've been diving
what do you do with your hair when you
die
uh i haven't had my hair this long since
i've been diving so i don't know what i
would do with it turtle might think it's
a jellyfish
where would you go on vacation would you
go diving
diving
did you like it
it's close
is
you don't want to go snorkeling with
cody he's going to throw up in that
thing
no i throw up on the boat you get off
the boat you're fine
you're fine in the water yeah they only
get seasick on the boat
that's wonderful
i've done this a lot i know where i get
sick give it up for cody and kara
the last couple
of our show other people
thank you guys so much for coming out
and going on a date together
feel free to exchange numbers afterwards
kiss in the green room if you want well
not twice
a
any couples that were on the show and
want to consummate
green room
but uh thank you guys so much for coming
out how did you enjoy yourself bianca
what did you think about all the couples
that you saw tonight made me feel a lot
better about my current dating life
which wasn't i didn't know how to feel
about it before this but i think i got a
lot of potential comparing
what's going on in here
you got good questions lined up for them
next time you go on a date it's like
i've i've done this before you're like a
professional yeah next time we go on a
date i'm gonna be like okay so what's
the country you don't want to go do the
most
uh give it up for bianca parado or a
guest for the show tonight my name is
hans kim thank you guys so much for
coming out and have a good night thank
you
um
me
[Music]
[Music]
now
here